YUFEI ZHAO: Last
time, we started
discussing the extremal
problem for bipartide graphs.
And in particular, we saw
the Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem,
which tells us that if you
forbid your graph from having
a complete bipartide
graph, Kst, then
you have this upper bound on the
number of edges in your graph.
So we gave a proof.
It was fairly short, used
the double counting argument,
and it give you this bound.
And the next question is
how tight is this bound?
Is there a lower bound
that is off by, let's say,
at most a constant factor?
And that's a major open problem.
It's a conjecture that
this bound is tight
up to constant factors.
But that conjecture is known
for only a very small number
of graphs.
And we saw a couple
of examples last time.
So last time we saw
construction that
shows that for S equals
to 2, this bound is tight.
So the extremal number for k
through 2 is on the order of n
to the 3/2.
So this theta means I'm
hiding constant factors.
And our construction
used this polarity graph,
which is essentially
the point line incidence
graph of a projective plane.
And a basic algebraic or
geometric fact, if you will,
that two lines intersecting
at most one point.
We also sketched a
construction that
showed that for S equals to
3, this bound is also tight.
And this construction
here involved
using spheres, again, in some
space over a finite field.
So both these constructions
are in some sense
algebraic geometric.
And you can ask, is
there a way to extend
these ideas to construct other
examples of Kst free graphs
with the right number of
edges using some ingredients
from algebraic geometry?
And today, I want to show
you two different ways
of doing that.
So the state of the art,
which I mentioned last time,
let me remind you what is
known about constructions
that achieve the right
exponent up there.
So in a series of two
papers by [INAUDIBLE]
it is shown that if
the constants t and s,
such that t is large
enough compared to s,
in particular t is bigger
than s minus 1 factorial,
then the extremal
number of Kst's is
of the order, same
order, as given
in the upper bound of the
Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem.
In particular, these range of
parameters allows you to do
(2, 2), (3, 3), which we
already know how to do.
But the next case is 4, 7.
And it is still
open how to do 4, 6.
So I want to show you
this construction.
And I will tell you
exactly what the graph is.
I'll give you an
explicit description
of this graph, which is Kst
free and has lots of edges.
And as I mentioned earlier, it
is an algebraic construction.
So as before, we
start with p prime.
And we will take n to be
a p raised to the power s.
And let's restrict s to
be integer at least 2.
And, of course, that's
same as last time,
if you have other values
of n, take a prime close
to the desired value and
then take it from there.
To describe the construction,
let me remind you,
the norm map, if you have a
field extension, in this case,
specifically I am looking
at the field extension,
this Fp to the s, I can
define a norm map as follows.
Sending x to be the product
of all the conjugates,
or the Galois conjugates of
x, in this field extension.
So explicitly written out
is just that expression,
which I can clean and collect
and write it down like this.
So I wrote that the
image of this norm map
lies in the base field Fp.
And that is because--
well, one of the many
reasons why this is the case,
is that if you look at--
so I'll denote this
norm map by N--
if you look at N of x,
it raised to power p,
leaves this value unchanged.
And the base field
is the field where it
is invariant under power by p.
So here's the graph,
which I'll denote the norm
graph with parameters p and s.
So the norm graph will have
as vertices just the elements
of this field extension.
And the edges will be the set
of all pairs of vertices, not
equal, of course, such that a
norm of their sum equals to 1.
So that's the graph.
This is an explicit description
of what the vertices
and what the edges are.
So now, we need to verify
a couple of things.
One is that this graph has
the desired number of edges.
It has lots of edges.
And two is that this
graph is Kst free.
So let's do both
of those things.
So the first is let's check it
has the right number of edges.
So that's a
relatively easy task.
What we need to do is
to count for every a
how many choices of b are
there in this field extension
such that a plus b
has norm exactly 1?
And I claim that that number--
well, so here's a
basic algebra fact,
that the number of elements in
this field extension with norm
exactly 1 is precisely
p to the s minus 1
divided by p to the s.
And this is because
really we're looking
in the multiplicative subgroup.
So the multiplicative
group in this Fp to the s.
And it has a cyclical--
so there's a generator--
the order of the cyclic
group is p to the s minus 1.
So you're asking,
how many elements
when raised to this power
here ends up at the identity?
So that's the answer.
So that's one aspect.
And so as a result, every
vertex is adjacent to, well,
how many vertices?
For every given a I
need to solve for b.
And basically, this
many solutions,
I have to be just
slightly careful because I
don't want loops in my graph.
So I may need to subtract 1.
So it's adjacent to at least
this number up here minus 1
to account for possible
loops, which is pretty large,
p to the s minus 1,
which in other words
is n raised to 1 minus 1
over s, that many vertices,
and you see that this gives
you the right number of edges.
So this is a graph
with lots of edges.
So that part wasn't so hard.
The next part,
it's much trickier,
which is we want to check
that this graph has no Kst's.
So previously in our
algebraic construction,
we used some geometric
facts, such as no two lines
intersect in more than one point
to show that there's no k to 2
in the polarity graph.
So there's going to be
something like that here.
So the claim is that this
construction, this norm graph,
is Ks, s factorial plus 1 free.
So it's not quite
the bound I claimed.
So it's a little bit weaker.
But it is in the spirit
of what I am claiming,
namely that for t large
enough, this graph is Kst free.
So for t a large enough
comes constant here
will show s factorial plus 1.
And as a result, it would follow
that the extremal number 4s
sub s factorial plus
1 is at least 1/2
minus little 1 of the constant--
I don't already worry
about that much,
but it's on the order of
n to the 2 minus 1 over s.
OK, everyone with me?
So we need to verify this
graph here has no Kst.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Should that t be an s?
YUFEI ZHAO: Yes,
that should be an s.
Thank you.
Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: Should that
be s minus 1 factorial?
YUFEI ZHAO: So we
will show later
on a better result using
s minus 1 factorial,
but for now I'll show you the
slightly weaker result, which
is still in the same spirit.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is the stronger
result using the same graph?
YUFEI ZHAO: We'll change
to a different graph.
For the stronger result, we will
change to a different graph.
OK, so now let's show that
this graph here is Kst free.
And for that claim, we need to
invoke an algebraic fact, which
let me write down now.
So suppose we have a field f.
Any field will work
with a finite field.
Any field is fine.
And I have a bunch of
elements from the field,
such that a sub ij is
different from a sub
rj for all i not the same as r.
Then the system of equations--
and I'll write down the system.
So x minus 1--
x1 minus a 1, 1, x2
minus a 1, 2, and so on.
xs minus a1x equals to b1.
That's the first equation.
Second equation,
x1 minus a 2, 1.
It almost looks like the usual
system of linear equations.
But I'm taking products.
And so on.
So the last one being x1 minus
a s1 x2 minus a s2, dot dot dot,
xs minus a ss equals to b sub s.
The system has at most s
factorial solutions, where
I'm working inside this field.
So that's the claim.
So let me just give you some
intuition for this claim.
Suppose the right side
vector is 0, all zeroes.
Then I claim that
this is trivial.
So what is the saying?
I need to select x1 to be one
of the a's from the first row
and x2 be one of the a's from
the second row, and so on.
But each column
of a is distinct.
So that's the hypothesis.
You have all the a's in the
first column are distinct.
So no two of the x's can--
so I need to set one
of the xi's to be one
of the a's from the first row.
But you see that you
cannot set x1 to be a 1, 1,
and x1 to be a s1
at the same time.
So the solution just
counts permutations,
which is exactly s factorial.
So this algebraic
fact plays a key role
in the proof of the theorem
that the lower bound
that we're stating up there,
if you look at the paper,
they give a proof
of this result.
And it's not a long proof.
But it uses some commutative
algebra and algebraic geometry.
And usually in a class,
if the instructor
doesn't present the proof, it's
for one of several reasons.
Maybe the proof is too short.
It doesn't need to be presented.
Maybe it's too long or
too difficult. Maybe
it's not instructive
to the class.
And the last reason,
which is the case here,
is that I don't actually
understand the proof.
As in I can follow
it line by line,
but I don't understand
why it is true.
And if one of you wants to
come up with a different proof
or try to explain to
me how this seemingly
elementary algebraic fact is
proved, I would appreciate it.
For small values of x,
you can check it by hand.
So x equals to 2,
you're solving a system
of two quadratic equations.
And that you can check by hand.
And three maybe you can
do it with some work.
But even with 4 it's not
so clear how to do it.
And also, one of the geometric
intuition is that if b is o0,
then you have exactly
s factorial solutions.
And the geometric
intuition is somehow
that if you move b
around, then the fiber,
the sides of the fiber,
the number of solutions x
can only go down.
It can not go up.
And this corresponds to some
algebraic geometry phenomenon.
And that's all I will say about
this algebraic fact, which
we'll now use as a black box.
Great.
So now we have that as
our algebraic input,
let us show that a
norm graph is Kst free.
It's actually not
so hard once you
assume that theorem up there.
So let's show at a norm graph
is Ks, s factorial plus 1 free.
Well, what does it
mean to have a Kst?
It means that if you
have distinct vertices,
which then correspond
to elements,
s elements, y1 through
ys, of this field,
then the common neighbors
of these elements
correspond to solutions of
this system of equations
where I set all of
these values to be 1.
But I can write l exactly
what these guys are
because I have this form,
that representation there
for the norm map, so
I can write it out.
And now remember
this fact that when
you are in characteristic p, x
plus y raised to the power p,
is the same as x to the p
plus yp and characteristic p.
So I can expand the remaining
parenthesis like that.
So I want the first line
to equal to 1, and so on.
And each of the lines
has that equal to 1.
How many solutions in x does
this system of equations have?
So even if I treat each
of x and x to the p
and so on as separate
variables, that theorem
appear tells me that there are
at most s factorial solutions
in x.
Satisfies all the hypotheses
of that theorem up there.
Therefore, the graph is Ks
sub s factorial plus 1 free.
You do not have more than
s plus 1 different values
of x satisfying this
system of equations.
And that's the proof that
this norm graph is Kst free.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Why can't
powers of like [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry, can
you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: Why cannot the
powers of the y's be the same?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is why
cannot the powers of the p's be
the same?
So you are asking,
down the second column,
let's say, why are all
these y's different?
Because you're working
inside a field.
And raising to a p in
this field is a bijection.
So think about the order
of the cyclic group.
It has co-prime to p.
But great question.
Anything else?
OK, so this gives
you a construction
that gives you Kst free for t
bigger than s plus s factorial.
Now, let me show you how to
improve this construction
to do a little bit better,
to get s minus 1 factorial.
And the idea is
to take a variant
of this norm graph, which we'll
call the projective norm graph.
And the projective norm
graph will define it
for s at least 3
is rather similar.
But there's a twist.
I have as the vertex set, not
just the field extension--
OK, so now I take field
extension, but one level less.
And I take a second
coordinate, which consists
of non-zero elements from Fp.
The edges are formed by putting
an edge between these two
elements, if and
only if, the norm
of the sum of the
first coordinates
equals to the product of
the second coordinates.
So now, you can run through
a similar calculation that
tells you the number of edges.
So first of all, the
number of vertices
is p to the s minus
1 times p minus 1,
so basically the same as p to s.
And additionally, every
vertex has degree exactly
p raised to s minus 1 minus 1.
And the reason is that if I tell
you the values of x little x
and big y, which
cannot equal minus x,
or else you will
never form an edge,
then they together uniquely
determine little y.
So for every value of
big X and little x,
I just need to run through
all the values of big Y other
than minus x.
So the number of edges
then equals to 1/2 times
the number of vertices times the
degree of every vertex, which,
as before, is the
claimed asymptotic.
And the remaining thing to show
is that this projective norm
graph is Kst free.
So it's K sub s, s minus
1 factorial plus 1 free.
It's a similar calculation
as the one before,
but we need to take into
account the small variant
in the construction.
So suppose we fix s vertices,
labeled by this big Y's, little
y's.
And now we need to
solve for uppercase X,
lowercase x in this
system of equations,
so asking how many different
pairs, big X, little
x, can appear as a solution
to this system of equations?
Well, first of all, if some
pairs of the first coordinates,
big I is equal to big J,
then if you have a solution,
then that forces little y
to be the same as little j.
And so the y's wouldn't have
been distinct to begin with.
So this is not possible.
So all the big Y's are distinct.
Well, now, let's
divide these equations
by the final equation.
And we get that
the i-th equation
becomes like that,
which you can rewrite
by dividing by the coordinate
of the norm of big Y i
minus big Y s.
This is non-zero because we
just showed that all the big Y
i's are distinct.
If you divide by this norm here
and rearrange appropriately,
we find that the equations
become like this.
So after doing some
rearranging-- so
this is the equation the set
of new questions that we get.
And you see that if you
use new variables, x prime,
do a substitution,
this being x prime,
then it has basically
the same form as the one
that we just saw with a
different set of constants.
And in particular
from what we just saw,
we see that you cannot have
more than s minus 1 factorial
solutions in x.
Now, they're s
minus 1 equations.
And the field extension
working as the x minus 1
field extension.
So we saved an equation by
using this projectivization.
And that's it.
So this shows you the
claim of constructing
a Kst free graph for t bigger
than s minus 1 factorial, which
has the desired number of edges.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Why do you
have the if some capital
Y equals capital IJ?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so the question
is why do I say this part?
So I'm maybe
skipping a sentence.
I'm saying, if there is
a solution to this system
of equations x, if
these vertices have
a common neighbor, then if
you have some x satisfying
this system of equations, then
having two different big Y's
being the same forces you
to have the two smaller y's
being the same.
AUDIENCE: OK.
YUFEI ZHAO: Right.
And then the Y's will
have been distinct.
So for them to have
some common neighbors,
you better have these
big Y's being distinct.
Any more questions?
Great.
So as I mentioned,
it is an open problem
to determine whether what is the
extremal number for K44, K45,
K46.
And you may ask, well, we
have this nice construction--
it maybe somewhat mysterious
because of that, but explicit.
And you can write
this graph down.
And you can ask is
this graph K46 free?
So do we gain one
extra number for free,
maybe because we didn't
analyze things properly?
And it turns out
that's not the case.
So there was a very recent
paper just released last month
showing that this graph here
for s equals to 4 actually does
contain some K46's.
So if you want to prove a
corresponding lower bound
for K46, you better come up
with a different construction.
And that's I think an
interesting direction
to explore.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we know
of any similar results
about this construction
not working for larger s?
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is, do we
know any similar result of
about does this graph contain
Kst for other values
of s and t less
than the claimed threshold?
It is unclear.
So the paper that
was uploaded, it
doesn't address the
issue of s bigger than 4.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why Fp to the power s?
YUFEI ZHAO: So question is
why Fp to the power of s?
So let's go back to the
norm graph construction.
So where do we use
Fp to the power of s?
Well, certainly we needed it
to have the right edge count.
So that comes up
in the edge count.
And also in the
norm expression, you
have the correct
number of factors.
So I encourage you
to try for if you
use a smaller or
bigger value of s,
you either don't get
something which is Kst free
or you have the wrong
number of edges.
Any more questions?
So later, I will show you
a different construction
of Kst free graphs, again,
for t large compared to s
that will not do as
well as this one.
But it is a genuinely
different construction.
And it uses the idea
of randomized algebraic
construction, which is
something that actually was only
developed a few years ago.
It's a very recent development.
And it's quite nice.
So it combines some of the
things we've talked about
with constructing using
random graphs to construct
H free graphs on one hand,
and on the other hand,
some of the algebraic ideas.
In particular, we're not going
to use that theorem up there,
but we'll use some other
algebraic geometry fact.
OK, so let's take a quick break.
So what I want to discuss
now is a relatively new idea
called a randomized
algebraic construction, which
combines some ideas from both
the randomized construction
and also the algebraic
construction that we just saw.
So this idea is due to Boris
Bukh just a few years ago.
And the goal is to give an
alternative construction
of a Kst free graph
with lots of edges
provided that as before, t
is much larger compared to s.
So this band here will
not be as good as the one
that we just saw.
And I will even
tell you what it is.
But it's some constant.
So for every s there
is some t, such
that this construction works.
As before, we working inside
some finite field geometry.
So let's start with
a, a prime power.
You can think of
prime if you like.
It doesn't make so
much difference.
So we're working
inside a finite field.
And let's assume s is
fixed and at least 4.
Let me write down
some parameters.
Don't worry about them for now.
Just think of them as
sufficiently large constants.
So d is this quantity here.
So we'll come back to it
later when it comes up.
OK, so what's the idea?
When we looked at the
randomized construction,
we took a random graph.
We took an Erdos Renyi graph.
Every edge appeared
independently.
And saw that it
has lots of edges,
if you choose p property
and not so many copies of h.
So you can remove
all the copies of h
to get a graph with lots
of edges that is h free.
What we're going to
do now is instead
of taking the edges
randomly, we're
going to take a
random polynomial.
F will be a random
polynomial chosen uniformly
among all polynomials with--
so I wrote uppercase Y and
uppercase X and Y. Actually, X
and Y, they're not
single variants.
They are-- so each of them
is a vector of s variables.
So in other words, x1
through xs are the variables
in the polynomial.
And then y1 through ys.
So it's a 2s
variable polynomial.
So among all polynomials
with degree, at most d--
d being the number up here--
in each of x and y
sets of variables.
So you look at it
as xs variables,
each monominal has
their exponents sum
to our most d, and likewise
with each monomial for the y
variables.
So this is the random object.
It's a random polynomial
in 2s variables.
And the degree is bounded.
So you only have a finite
number of possibilities,
and I choose one of them
uniformly at random.
And now, what's my graph?
We're going to construct
a bipartide graph
G. The bipartideness,
it's not so crucial.
But it'll make our
life somewhat easier.
So it's a bipartide graph.
So it hs two vertex parts, which
I will label left and right,
L and R. And they are both
the s dimensional vector
space over f cube.
And we'll put an edge
between two vertices,
if and only if that
polynomial up there
f evaluates to 0
on these values.
That's the graph.
So I give you a
random polynomial f.
And then you put in edges
according to when f vanishes.
So f, if you view the bipartide
graph as a subset of Fq
to s cross F to the s,
then this is the zero set.
The edge set is the zero set.
Just like in random graphs,
with the construction
with random graphs, we'll need
to show a couple of things.
One is that has lots of edges,
which will not be hard to show.
And second, that it will
have typically a small number
of copies of Kst.
And that will have
some ingredients which
are similar to the random
graphs case we saw before,
but it will have some new ideas
coming from algebraic geometry.
First, let's show that this
graph has lots of edges.
And that's a simple calculation,
because for every pair
of points of vertices, I
claim that the probability--
so here f is the random object--
the probability that f evaluates
to 0 on this pair is exactly q.
So exactly 1 over q, 1
over the size of the field.
So this is not too hard.
And the reason is that
the distribution of f
is identical to if you are an
extra random constant on f,
chosen uniformly at random.
So I took a random polynomial.
I shifted by a random constant.
It's still uniformly
random polynomial,
according to that distribution.
But now, you see
that this, whatever f
evaluated to, if I shift
by a random constant,
you will end up with a
uniform distribution.
So it tells you that that guy
up there is uniform distribution
on every fixed point
u, v. So in particular,
it hits 0 with probability
exactly 1 over q.
And as a result, the number of
edges of g in the expectation
is exactly n squared
over q, where
n is the number of vertices.
So n is actually not
the number of vertices,
but the size of each vertex
part, namely q to the s.
So you see that it gives you
the right number of edges, so n
to the 2 minus 1 over s.
So we have the right
number of edges.
And now, we want to show that
this graph here typically does
not have too many
copies of Kst's.
It might have some
Somehow that is unavoidable.
Just as in the random case, you
do have some copies of Kst's.
But if they are not
too many copies,
I can remove them and
obtain a Kst free graph.
OK, so what is the intuition?
How does it compare
to the case when
you have a genuine
Erdos-Renyi random graph?
Well, what is the expected
number of common neighbors?
So if you fix some
u with let's say
on the left side with
exactly s vertices,
I want to understand, how many
common neighbors does u have?
But because the
common neighbors,
if he has too many common
neighbors, then that's a Kst.
It is not hard to
calculate the expectation
of this quantity, both
in the random graph case
as well as in this case.
And you can calculate if you
pretend every edge occurs
independently, the expected
number of common neighbors
is exactly n to the
q to the minus s.
So there are s elements
of u, which is exactly 1.
And you know that for a binomial
distribution with expectation 1
and a large number of
variables, the distribution
is approximately Poissonian.
Ah, but that's in the case when
it's independently distributed,
which is the case
in the case of GMP.
But it turns out for
the algebraic setting
we're doing here, things
don't behave independently.
It's not that you're doing coin
flops for every possible edge.
We're doing some randomized
algebraic construction.
And for algebraic
geometry reasons,
you will see that the
distribution is very much not
like Poissonian.
It will turn out that either
the number of common neighbors
is bounded or it is very large.
And that means that we can show
using some Markov inequality
that the probability that it
is very large is quite small.
So typically, it will not
have many common neighbors?
And that's the intuition, and so
let's work out this intuition.
Any questions so far?
So how do we do
this calculation?
So first, let's start
with something that's
actually fairly elementary.
So suppose you have some
parameters, r and s.
So I think of r and s--
so I have some
parameters r and s.
And thick of them as constants.
Have some restrictions,
but don't worry too much
about them.
Suppose I have two bounded
subsets of the finite field,
where you have size
s and v has size r.
Then the claim is
that the probability
that f vanishes on the Cartesian
product of u and v. OK,
so what do you expect it to be?
So I have s r elements, and I
want f, this random polynomial,
to vanish on the entire product.
Well, if s, its value behaved
independently for every point,
you should expect that
the probability is exactly
q to the power minus s r.
And it turns out
that is the case.
So this is true.
This is an exact statement.
OK, so why is this true?
So this is in some
sense a generalization
of this claim over here.
And you have to do a
little bit more work.
But it's not too difficult.
So let's first
consider this lemma
in a somewhat simpler case,
where all the first coordinates
of x are distinct--
of u are distinct.
And all the first coordinates
of v are distinct.
Suppose u and v have that form.
So I write down the
list of points for u
and first coordinates
are all distinct.
What I want to do is to
give you a random shift,
to do a uniform random shift.
And I will shift it by
a polynomial g, which
is a bivariate polynomial.
So these are not vectors.
They are just single variables.
And I look at all
possible sum of monomials,
where the degree in i is less
than s, and the degree in j
is less than r.
And these a's are chosen
uniformly independently
at random from the
ground field fq.
And as before, we see
that f and f plus g
have the same distribution, the
same probability distribution.
And so all it remains to show
that is whatever f comes out
to be, if I tack on
this extra random g,
it creates a uniform
distribution on the values
on the entire u cross
v. But, actually, see,
I have sr choices exactly
for these coefficients.
And I have sr values that
I'm trying to control.
So really it's a
counting problem.
And it suffices to show
a bijection, namely
that for every possible
vector of values,
there exists a choice
of coefficients,
as above, such that g evaluates
to the prescribed values
with the given coefficients.
And that uniformity will follow
just because you have the exact
if you just do a counting.
And the one-dimensional
version of this claim,
so let's think
about what that is.
So if I have, let's say,
three points on the line
and a degree 2 polynomial,
what I am saying
is that if you give me the
values you want on these three
points, I can produce for
you a unique polynomial that
evaluates to the prescribed
values on these three points.
And that you should all know
as Lagrange interpolation.
So it tells you
exactly how to do that.
And that works for many reasons.
One of them is that the random
indeterminate is invertible.
Here, we have multi-variables.
So let's do Lagrange
interpolation twice, once
for each variable.
So we'll apply Lagrange
interpolation twice.
So the first time, we'll see
that for all values of u,
there exists a single
variate polynomial
in the y variable with
degree at most r minus 1 that
evaluates to the correct
values on the fixed little u.
So do it for one
variable at a time.
For fixed u, do
Lagrange interpolation
on the y variable.
And now, once we have
those things there,
viewing the g that we want
to find as a polynomial whose
coefficients are polynomials in
the x variables, but is itself
is a polynomial
in the y variable,
we find that again using
Lagrange interpolation,
there exists these values
for these coefficients
here, such that each
coefficient of if you plug
in the first entry into little
u agrees with the coefficients
of the g that we just found.
And that should be the
case for every little u.
So once you find
these polynomials
and now you have a
bonafide polynomial in g.
And that's the claim above.
So using Lagrange interpolation
twice, once for each variable.
So this is-- if you're
confused, just think about it.
There is nothing deep here.
So that finishes the
claim in the case
when the first coordinates
are all distinct.
So we use that fact crucially
in doing this Lagrange
interpolation.
Now, for general
u and v, where we
don't have this
assumption of having
distinct first
coordinates, well,
let's make them to have
distinct first coordinates
by considering a random
linear transformation,
so using a probabilistic method.
So we suffice as to find
invertible linear maps, p
and s, on this vector space,
such that TU and SV have
the above properties.
So let me show you
how to do it for u.
So I need to find you
a invertible linear
transformation t.
Well, it's just the first
coordinate that matters.
So it suffices to
find just a linear map
corresponding to the
first coordinate that
is injective of u.
Whatever linear map you have,
even if it's zero, that's fine,
I can extend it to the
remaining coordinates.
Actually, if it's
zero, then it's
not going to be injective of u.
So it better not be zero.
OK, well, let's find
this map randomly.
So pick t uniform via random
among all linear maps.
And I want to understand
what is the probability
of collision, bad event,
if two elements of u
end up getting mapped
to the same point.
Well, that's not too hard.
So for every distinct pair
of points in fq to the s
the probability
that they collide,
think about why this is true.
It's exactly 1 over q.
If x and x prime, they're
differing at least one
coordinate, then even just
along that coordinate,
I can make them distinct.
So this is the case
for every pair.
So now by union
bound, the probability
that t1 is injective on u
is at least 1 minus the size
if u choose 2 times 1 over q.
And that's why we chose
q to be large enough.
So q is at least r squared, s
So this number here is positive.
So such a t exists.
And so we can transform this u
and v, two configurations where
the first coordinates
are all distinct,
and then run the
argument as before.
OK, great.
So what we've shown so far is
that if you look at these Ksr
structures, they appear
with probability exactly--
well, with expectation
exactly what
you might expect as in
independent random case.
But what we really
want to understand
is the distribution of the
number of common neighbors.
In particular, we want to
upper bound the probability
that there are too
many common neighbors.
We want to understand some
kind of tail probabilities.
And to do that, one way
to do tail probabilities
is to consider moments.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry, can
you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: How do you
have the equality right
before the lemma?
YUFEI ZHAO: Question, how
do I have the equality right
before the lemma?
So there, I'm actually saying
for the Erdos-Renyi random
graph case--
that's the case-- in
Erdos-Renyi random graph,
each edge, if you have the same
edge probability, is 1 over q.
And then that's the
number of common neighbors
you would expect.
So that's a heuristic for the
Erdos-Renyi random graph case.
OK, so now let's
try to understand
the distribution of the
number of common neighbors.
So let's fix a u subset of Fp to
the s with exactly s elements.
And I want to understand how
many common neighbors it has.
So let's consider the number
of common neighbors of u
and the d-th moment of
this random variable.
So this is a common way
to do upper tail bounds.
And one way to
analyze such moments
is to decompose this count
as a sum of indicator
random variables.
So let me write I of v to be the
quantity which is 1 if f of uv
is 0 for all with ou
and big U. In the words,
it's a common neighbor.
It's 1 if v is a common
neighbor for u, and 0 otherwise.
So then the number
of common neighbors
would simply be the sum of
this indicator as v ranges
over the entire vertex set.
And I can expand the sum.
Then all of these
are standard things
to do when you're trying
to calculate moments.
OK, so I can bring
this expectation inside
and try to understand what is
the expectation of this object
inside.
Well, if all the
v's are distinct,
then this is simply the
expected number of Kst's.
But the v's might
not be distinct.
So we need to be a
little bit careful.
But that's not too
hard to handle.
So let me write M sub
r to be the number
of subjective functions from
d element set to an r elements
set, an M to be sum of these
M sub r's for r up to d.
Then, let's consider how many
distinct v values are there.
If there are distinct
v values, then they
take on that many
possible values.
And Mr for the number
of subjections,
and for each possible
r, the exact number
for the exact value
of this expectation
is q to the minus rs.
And that's exactly
what we showed.
So this comes from
the lemma just now.
But we chose-- I
mean, look, this
is that binomial coefficient.
And you have this number here.
So they multiply
it to at most 1.
So we have this number,
this quantity there,
which I think of as a constant.
So this is a constant.
So the d-th moment is bounded.
And one way to get tail bounds
once you have the moments
is that we can use
Markov's inequality.
It tells us that the number
of common neighbors of u,
the probability that u has too
many common neighbors, more
than lambda common neighbors.
I can rewrite this
inequality here
by raising both
sides to the power d.
And then, using Markov
inequality, take expectation.
So all of these are
standard techniques
for upper tail estimation.
You want to understand the
upper tails on random variable,
understand its moments and
use Markov on its moments.
But now, we know we have some
bound for the d-th moment,
right?
Which is M as we just showed.
So there is this bound here.
So far you can run
the same argument
in the random graphs case.
And you wouldn't really
do much different.
I mean everything is
more or less the same
what I've said so
far, although we
had to do a special
calculation algebraically that
didn't really make sense--
I mean, that you have to show
some kind of near independence.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is that less
than or equal to, right?
The Markov inequality.
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, thank you.
So this is less
than or equal to.
Thank you.
But now is where the
algebra comes in,
so the algebraic geometry nature
of this argument comes in.
It turns out that
this quantity here--
previously, we said,
at least heuristically,
in the random graphs case,
it behaves like a qua Poisson
random variable.
So it's fairly uniform
in a Poisson sense.
It turns out because
of the algebraic nature
of the construction,
this random variable
behaves nothing like a Poisson.
So it turns out it's highly
constrained due to reasons
using algebraic geometry.
And I'll tell you exactly why.
So that the number
of common neighbors
is either very
small or very large.
And here is the claim
that for every s and d,
there exists some
c, such that if I
have a bunch of polynomials
on fq to the s of degree
o at most d, then if you
look at the number of zeros,
common zeros, of the f's, how
many common zeros can you have?
It turns out it cannot just
be some arbitrary number.
So this set has size
either bounded at most c.
Or it is at least q minus
something very small.
And I'll explain
just a little bit
why this is the case, although
I will not give a proof.
So either somehow
you are working
in a zero dimensional case, or
if this algebraic variety that
comes with it has
positive dimension,
then you should have
a lot more points.
And the reason
for this dichotomy
has to do with how
many points are there
on the algebraic variety
over a finite field?
So I will not give a
proof, although if you
look on the course website
for a link to a reference,
that does have a proof.
But I will tell you what
the key algebraic geometric
input is to that claim up here.
And this is a important
and famous theorem
called a Lang Weil bound.
So the Lang Weil bound
tells you that if you
have an algebraic variety, v.
And for now, it is important
in order to say this properly to
work in the algebraic closure,
so Fq bar as the
algebraic closure,
it's the smallest field
extension where I can
solve all polynomial equations.
Then, the variety cut out
by a set of polynomials--
so v is this variety.
So if it is irreducible, it
cannot be written as a union
of finite number of
smaller varieties,
irreducible over Fq bar.
And all of these polynomials
have degree bounded.
Then the question is, if
I take these polynomials
and I look at how many
Fq points does it have?
So in other words,
now I leave the field.
I come back down to Earth,
to the base field and ask,
what's the number
of solutions where
the coordinates are in Fq?
OK, so how many
points do we expect?
Well, the simplest example
of an algebraic variety
is that of a subspace.
If you have a d-dimensional
subspace over Fq,
you have q to the
d points exactly.
So you expect something like
q raised to the dimension
of the variety.
Now the dimensions is actually
a somewhat subtle concept.
I won't define.
But there are many definitions
in algebraic geometry.
It turns out it's not
always exactly as nice
as in the case of
linear subspaces.
But the Lang Weil bound tells
us that is not too far off.
You have a deviation
that is at most
on the order of q 1
over root q, where
there are some hidden
constants depending
on the description of
your variety in terms
of the degrees of the
polynomial with the dimension
and the number of polynomials.
But the point is that the
number of points on this variety
is basically should be
around the same as the model
case, namely that of a subspace.
And that brings
us some intuition
to why this lemma is true.
So you have those
polynomials up there.
So there are some
subtle points one
needs to verify about
your disability,
but the punchline
is that either you
are in the zero-dimensional
case, in which case
you have something like
[INAUDIBLE] theorem,
and that tells you that a
number of solutions is bounded.
Or you're in the positive
dimensional case, in which case
the Lang Weil term
tells you, you
must have lots of solutions.
And there is no middle ground.
And now, we're ready to finish
off Boris Bukh's construction.
So we see that applying this
lemma up there with this, what
should be my polynomials be?
I'm going to use my polynomials
f sub u of y to be--
well, I have a random
polynomial up there.
So I'm trying to find
common neighbors.
I'm trying to find
common solutions.
So these are my polynomial
as u ranges over big U.
So for q large enough,
we find that the number
of common neighbors of u, the
probability that it is bigger
than c, where c is
supplied by that lemma,
is equal to the probability that
a number of common neighbors
of u exceeds q over 2, where
q over w is this quantity
rounded--
smaller than that
quantity up there.
So if it has more
than c solutions,
that automatically has
a lot of solutions.
And now, we can apply the
Markov inequality up there,
the tail bound on the moments to
deduce that this probability is
at most M divided by q over
2 raised to the power d.
And the moral of it
is that we should
have a very small number--
I mean, this should occur
with very small probability.
So let's call u being a subset
of v bad if u has r elements, u
is contained entirely on the
left side or the right side
of the original bipartition.
And most importantly, u has
a lot, namely more than c,
common neighbors in j.
So how many bad
sets do we expect?
Basically, a very small number.
So the number of
bad sets, bad use,
is upper bounded by-- well,
for each choice of s elements,
the probability that
something is bad
is this quantity up here,
which we chose d to be a large
enough constant depending on s.
If you look at the
choice of d up there,
see that this quantity
here is quite a bit smaller
than the number of vertices.
And now, the last step is
the same as our randomized
construction using
Erdos-Renyi random graphs,
where we remove--
well, it's almost
the same, but now
we remove one vertex
from every bad set.
And we get some graph g prime.
And we just need to check that
g prime has lots of edges.
We know got rid of
all the bad sets.
So g prime is now K
sub sc plus 1 free.
We got rid of all possibilities
for s points having
more than c common neighbors.
Now, we just need to check
that g prime has lots of edges.
Well, the expected number
of edges in g prime
is at least the x--
what we removed one
vertex for every bad u.
And each bad u carries
with it at most n edges,
because there are only n edge
on each side of the bipartition.
And, well, the
number of edges of g
has expectations exactly
n squared over q.
And the number of bad u's we
saw up there is not very large.
So in particular, this
quantity, the second term
is dominated by the first term.
And so we obtain the
claimed number of edges.
Also, the graph has
at most 2n vertices.
So we may have gotten
got rid of some.
But actually, fewer
vertices, the better.
At most, 2n vertices,
and it is a case of s--
So it's Kst free
for t large enough.
So this gives you
another construction
of Kst free graphs.
And so today, we saw two
different constructions
of Kst free graphs for constants
s and t, but in both cases,
t is substantially
larger than s.
But the most important thing
is that they both match
the Kovari-Sos-Turan bound.
So it gives you some
evidence that maybe
the Kovari-Sos-Turan
conjecture, the theorem,
is tight up to at most a
constant factor, although that
is a major open problem.
And it remains a very difficult
it seems open problem, but one
that is of central importance
in extremal graph theory
to try to come up perhaps
with other constructions
that can do better.
Maybe they will have
some algebraic input.
But maybe they will have
some input from other ideas.
We do not know.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So is this q defined?
Because I remember
q as a prime power,
but it doesn't say there.
YUFEI ZHAO: So question
is, is q defined?
So just like in the proofs of
polarity graphs and what not--
so you have some n.
You rounded down to the
nearest prime powers.
So s is a constant.
So n is basically q to the s.
So take large n, round it down
to the nearest prime power.
q could be a prime,
for instance.
It could be a prime.
It could be a prime power.
Think q to be a prime.
So I'm saying for every q,
there is a construction.
And for every n, you can round
down to the nearest q to the s
and then run this construction.
Any more questions?
Great.
So next time I will begin by
telling you a few more things
about why people really
like this construction
and some conjectures that
were solved using this idea
and some conjectures
that still remain open
along the same lines.
And we'll also go beyond Kst,
so other bipartide graphs
and show you how
to do upper bounds
for those bipartide graphs.